[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the weekly climate
show and we're going down to the woods
today with an in-depth film from the
Amazon alongside a look at the global
Woody picture revealing where in the
world a tree cover is actually growing
we'll hear the latest from the global
climate Summit in Egypt cop 27 and what
about the weather here is it wet enough
for you is it wet enough to avoid
drought next year and we'll be asking if
we are finally seeing meaningful rain
but now we're heading to the trees the
Amazon jungle where so much Wildlife
dwells where so much carbon is stored
and millions of people live its survival
is key to a stable climate and it's kind
of at the heart of our shared Global
Environmental conscience
the Amazon basin is absolutely huge to
give you some idea of the scale it is
twice the size of India and 28 times
bigger than the UK it spans nine
countries across South America but most
of it lies in Brazil and under the
regime of the recently defeated
president jair bolsonaro deforestation
reached a record high satellite data
shows nearly 1500 square kilometers of
rainforest that's around the size of
greater London was chopped down in
September alone
uh Chief correspondent Stuart Ramsey
traveled to the state of rhondonia and
the indigenous territory of karapuna
where his team made this beautiful and
Powerful film
the pristine canopy of the Amazon
rainforest is breathtaking when seen
from the air
it is absolutely vast spanning nine
countries in South America
it's the most biodiverse place on the
planet home to 10 of the entire world's
wildlife
there are nearly 400 billion trees that
release billions of tons of water into
the air every day
and stores billions of tons of carbon in
their trunks and branches
the world needs the Amazon
but it is being destroyed on an
industrial scale every hour
from Brazil is the greatest Defender
this is one of the latest attacks on the
forest in the state of rondonia
teams of loggers move in for the wood
followed by teams clearing the land for
beef farming
this is completely illegal 95 percent of
it is
this belongs to an indigenous group and
it's being stolen
quandonia's rainforest is being
systematically destroyed it's one of the
worst affected areas in the country
the Amazon rainforest the Amazon River
and its enormous tributaries are home to
30 million people
many live a simple life in near
isolation on the banks of the river
but their livelihoods even their lives
are in danger from the spread of the
farming industry and its landground
vandelay dakuna joined us on the river
to show us the way to his friend's home
and whose land is being invaded by
Ranchers
vandelay used to live here we stopped
next to his former land
he was forced out one day when an armed
Rancher threatened to kill him foreign
in these remote areas there is Little
River traffic and little sign of life
you Glimpse the occasional house
sometimes passing moored canoes there
are people here you just don't see them
a couple of hours later we catch sight
of vandelay's friend and come ashore
he's bailing out water from his canoe
and it looks pretty swamped
he tells me however it was just last
night's reign
there's loads of these small communities
that they're really remote the problem
is
having to fight to hold on to their land
the farmers are encroached upon them
and so
they've got no choice but to try and
keep it under their Farms
and hope that they don't get invaded by
people who can be extremely violent
[Music]
these River people are not indigenous
but they're not commercial Farmers
either they basically live off the land
which they are licensed to hold and over
the years move within their territory
like the indigenous who they are close
to they can only cut down an acre or so
of trees a year
for the forest that is totally
sustainable
almir and Maria's land is being stolen
by commercial Farmers they're unable to
protect themselves and the authorities
do nothing to help them
it's left them angry and afraid of what
the future holds wow
foreign
of Brazil's rainforest has been cut down
over the past 50 years it may not sound
a lot but scientists warn of what they
call the Tipping Point that is when the
forest can't sustain its tropical
climate and basically dries out
The Tipping Point is at 25 of trees gone
it's that near
the Amazon rainforest is magnificent and
it looks pristine but actually Beyond
this tree line the land and the trees
have all been cut down and it's being
turned into farmland
and that is something that the
indigenous people keep making the point
is that their lands are being encroached
upon they fear that they're fighting a
battle that they may well lose and that
all of this will be gone one day
further Downstream we arrive at the home
of an indigenous group The karapuna
like so many of the indigenous groups in
the Amazon they depend on the forest and
the river to survive
the forest is disappearing and so too
are the animals and fish that the
indigenous live of
the karapuna have been here for
Generations
once remote their Community has been
decimated by disease from Outsiders
their numbers have dwindled now they are
losing their hunting land at an
astonishing rate
that well their leader Andre has just
returned from important meetings with
other indigenous heads
protecting their land dominates all
discussions between the groups
how are you nice to meet you
he introduced me to arepa of the older
surviving member of the karakuna who has
witnessed the devastated changes to the
forest
what do you think will happen to
not so much you but the next Generations
[Music]
Andre took us just three kilometers from
the karapuna village to show us how the
loggers and ranchers are moving in
this was pristine Forest just weeks ago
now it's a desolate Wasteland of fell
trees
the track to the Village was closed down
by the ranchers for a year as they set
to work on destroying the forest
and this is that this is what they put
in
so the effect is that it kills all
everything underneath and grows up thank
you
foreign
the destruction of the rainforest right
into the so-called protected land of the
indigenous communities is happening
across Brazil's Amazon
what were once tracks in our mud roads
and grass
fell trees are everywhere
only the castanera tree from which we
get the Brazil nut are left standing
cutting them down is completely illegal
and the wood can't be sold
but they're often dead anyway
well this is um what happens in the
Amazon and what's really interesting
actually and we're now in an area that
has been
attacked recently and deforested and
this tree behind us oh look at this
absolutely enormous
well one of it's been killed with fire
and so one of the enormous branches at
the top has come off
um blocking the
track that we're using to get to the
Village which is still a few miles away
Bravo
this is what the destruction is all
about enormous commercial Farms stretch
as far as the eye can see
this was all dense forest cleared away
for agricultural progress
intensive bee farming has made Brazil
the second biggest exporter in the world
after the United States
it's the fourth largest grain producer
and from its enormous soy plantations it
sends high protein cattle feed to
countries like China and Spain
chai Suri is the face of a new
generation of environmental activists
who speak truth to power
their message is simple the forest and
the people of the forest must be
protected or the world will suffer if I
ask you
[Music]
to sure that yeah I know that the Amazon
are burning
but they don't really know what Jesus
means
and Jesus means our death Jesus means
that they they they are not
cut the the trees but they are killing
us
they are in inside our land you know our
homes imagine you in your home
and
as somebody just getting
in Destroy Everything
and threat your family
and
and say yeah now just your home is mine
the world knows what's happened to the
Amazon rainforest and has called for it
to stop
but it isn't stopping in fact it's
actually getting worse
every year the deforestation record is
being broken
the forest and the people of the forest
need help
The Tipping Point is very near
Stuart Ramsey there in the Brazilian
Amazon let's broaden things out now and
look at deforestation across the globe
forests still cover nearly a third of
the world's land area but that figure is
shrinking since 1990 the world has lost
over 400 million hectares or about a
billion Acres of forest mainly in Africa
and South America however the rate of
loss has slightly slowed over the past
three decades in the most recent
five-year period 2015 to 2020 the annual
rate of deforestation was estimated at
10 million hectares down from 12 million
hectares for the five years before
and parts of the world gained a
significant area of tree cover over the
past two decades according to data from
the World Resources institute's Global
Forest watch nearly 131 million hectares
of land transitioned from having no
Forest to having one between 2000 and
2020. that's an area twice the size of
Ukraine
more than half of the newly planted land
was in Russia Canada and the United
States but they also felt huge swathes
of forest
but 36 countries have had a net gain in
Woodland in that 20-year period like
China India Poland Pakistan Algeria and
albeit modestly here in the UK
growing trees don't store much carbon
but they will in the future whereas
older trees hold carbon now and their
loss can release it to the atmosphere
and if you scan the QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to our
climate cast podcast where we look at
deforestation in more detail and the
impact of Brazil's recent election on
the future of the Amazon you can
subscribe to climate cast for free
wherever you get your podcasts
you're watching the climate show coming
up
it's been a pretty wet November but find
out why the rain hasn't been quite
meaningful enough to quench The Summer's
drought
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the climate
show with me Tom Heap the cop 27 Summit
is around halfway through in the
Egyptian Red Sea Resort of charmel
Sheikh and progress seems to be limited
I'll be in charm next week to see for
myself what's going on but earlier I
caught up with our climate change and
energy correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter
and asked how she sees it
where are we a weekend you know is it a
strange point after a week of wrangling
where diplomats and countries start
putting forward their sort of texts for
agreement I think we've had the entire
conversation though politically
dominated by this issue of loss and
damage poor and low-income Nations most
vulnerable to climate change having done
the least to cause it demanding
compensation now for from the rich
Nations who've driven the climate crisis
and wanting agreement about More Than
Just A continuing conversation here at
cop but I can tell you that Western
climate diplomats are really concerned I
mean particularly the Americans that the
loss and damage issue is kind of serving
as a bit of a distraction from the from
solving the the problem to be Frank from
from decarbonizing the world from
keeping 1.5 alive is it a bit like
arguing over who pays the Lifeboat as
the ship sinks
it's a really good good comparison I
think we'll see America steering the
conversation in another Direction
um I think that
there is a concern now amongst Western
climate diplomats that
this cannot be the Corp where 1.5 died
and
um I think they they have legitimate
concerns around some developing nations
resisting discussions about 1.5 I can
tell you it's not even on the formal
agenda for discussion now you can read
that in a couple of different ways you
could read it as though
actually Egypt is trying to tell the
world that 1.5 is is is baked in and
done doesn't need discussing but you
could also read it as there has been a
little bit of pushback from developing
nations who are under the impression
that 1.5 is just too hard to get to yeah
so there's this totem of 1.5 seems a
little bit missing in action currently
at the moment meanwhile outside of cops
some of the economics are moving to a
lower carbon world are moving in in the
right direction with fossil fuels being
high prices being high and likewise
investment and Renewables is there a
sort of potential coming together here
that the actual transition to a low
carbon World which is currently seen is
really expensive maybe doesn't have to
be and is that a kind of destination we
can reach
I think that's the thing that you're
you're hearing big developed economies
um makes the argument for that going
green is a massive Economic Opportunity
politicians want to set the framework
for that but it's it is actually the
case that that is what is happening to
the flow of climate Capital You know
despite government sometimes it's
becoming cheaper to go green renewable
energy is is the cheapest kind of power
we can make that's where investors are
going oil and gas are strong are going
to become stranded assets and the
investor Community isn't so interested
anymore and I think that's actually
what's underpinning what hope there is
at this cop
since I spoke to Hannah President Biden
has arrived in charm later in the week
than the rest of the world's leaders
because of the U.S midterm elections and
you can keep up to date with everything
that's happening throughout the summit
by scanning the QR code here which will
take you to our climate home page online
last week we asked you to send in your
questions and one people keep asking me
of late is are we getting enough rain to
make up for the part summer and why do
we still have some hose pipe bands cast
your mind back a few months in the
phrase we kept hearing from the Met
Office repeated by reporters like me was
that we need to see meaningful rain over
the winter meaningful rain I love the
idea of rain almost having a
philosophical purpose so dictionary
definite meaningful having a valid
meaning full of significance expressive
capable of interpretation but for those
in the Water Business it means higher
than average rainfall to recharge
Reserves this map from the Met Office
uses the darkest Brown to show where
there's been the least amount of rain
the lighter brown and the white is where
there's been most
East Sussex Kent West Sussex and the
Isle of Wight have all received all
their average November rainfall already
just in the first week and these were
some of the driest places in the summer
but in tone and where there's only been
12 percent of their November rainfall so
far
the Met Office still consider it to be a
dry year overall as so far we've had
just 71 percent of annual average
rainfall and by now it should be closer
to 85 percent and the environment
agencies say water companies still need
unusually heavy rain over winter months
to recover so if you're getting drenched
this Christmas take comfort it's
meaningful rain and as a footnote we are
aware that it's also been
extraordinarily warm lately
after watching our show last week about
carbon offsetting projects in Scotland
planting native trees podmore got in
touch with us via our app to ask why are
such projects not considering faster
growing but non-invasive species like
paulonia hemp seagrass or maybe even
bamboo well let's take a look at a few
of those first of all Scotland and what
we were filming last week well that was
a Scottish rally a Scottish race and the
organizers felt it was important for the
offsetting to happen within Scotland and
for projects there you really need to
look at things like native trees
conifers broadleafs and they'll be
getting to be planting those quite
shortly but you mentioned paulonia and
guess what we did a story about that in
the summer there's me sitting next to a
particularly weedy and small example but
it's gonna grow and it's going to grow
really fast and that as you suggest is
the point of paulonia trees and
interestingly there are some Estates in
east of England who are already seeking
carbon offset Finance to grow forests of
these trees you also mentioned sea grass
now sea grass isn't technically seaweed
it grows through photosynthesis in
shallow water around the coast it used
to be much more common just off the
coast of Britain now it's quite rare and
once again there are projects seeking to
expand its area I've seen them actually
kind of seeding it on the sea bed to get
these great Green Meadows under the
waves so once again it's a project that
may well as you suggest get carbon
offsetting Finance
and of course with love more questions
from you you can scan the QR code here
or go to any of our social media
accounts and put your questions in the
comments I'll be in charmel shakers cop
27 draws to a close next week and I'll
be answering some of those questions
with quite a bit of help from some
Summit delegates that's all from us this
week don't forget to join us next
weekend when we'll have that special
show from charmel Sheikh marking the
final days of the cop 27 Summit and
hopefully revealing some real progress
see you then
[Music]